clôture hier soir à mâcon de
l'université d'été des verts spectateurs
quelque peu impuissant de la guerre des
chefs qui oppose antoine waechter à
dominique voynet les militants
écologistes eux semblent quelque peu
désabusé ce qui ne l'a pas empêché de
faire la fête hier soir en bourgogne
reportage marie-hélène bonne ou alexis
marre
on les disait triste divisé même s'il ne
danse pas ensemble antoine waechter et
dominique voynet sont sur la même piste
il y aussi ceux qui regardent
l'essentiel étant de ne pas se marcher
sur les pieds tous sont d'accord pour
mettre de l'ordre dans un mouvement à
géométrie variable
les verts qui vont avoir 10 ans
connaissent une crise de croissance à
l'intérieur on dénonce une cacophonie
ambiante d'où la difficulté de
s'intégrer clairement dans le débat
politique les militants sont souvent
morose parfois sceptique mais pas
désabusé
je crois que ce serait crise est liée au
fait que
l'échec des verts c'est paniquant
l'échec des verts je passais l'échec de
la classe politique française vis-à-vis
de l'opinion je crois qu'à condition de
rester indépendant des autres formations
politiques on a encore des chances de
s'en sortir est de donner une place à
l'écologie politique en france et la
guerre des chefs passent aussi par la
réforme des statuts du mouvement antoine
waechter souhaite en finir avec la
collégialité les verts seraient
représentés par un secrétaire national
et un président ce que nous devons
réussir à faire c'est de trouver les
modalités de fonctionnement qui
permettent le dialogue et permettent de
réduire par conséquent la recherche de
rapports de force permanent pour
dominique voynet ce changement n'est pas
fondamental l'essentiel est d'être
d'accord sur les questions de fond
change et d'un porte parole à collégiale
pour une présidence qui ne changent pas
l'état d'esprit ça sert à rien et puis
un tel esprit silva par des règles de
pointe fixée par hugo monde pour savoir
si les verts rondins président
conserveront leur collégialité il faudra
attendre le vote final à l'assemblée
générale qui se tiendra à la mi novembre